[Music]
buy borrow die are you familiar with
this at all the buy borrow and die
approach
are you not familiar with it but i think
i could put it together you just you go
to a bunch of debt and then die is that
that what it is yeah basically that it's
like a it's like a sort of dynastic
approach to wealth transference whereby
you never you basically get everything
that you
need and want through leverage right i
mean obviously of risk of margin calls
and things like that as
we saw to dramatic effect
during
covet certainly some people were just
overextended and got their faces ripped
off including some very very famous
families i want to name but
how do you make sense of
conflicting
diametrically opposed advice from
seemingly
intelligent rational parties on both
sides i think you have to parse the
difference between what works on a
chalkboard and what works in real life
many years ago there was a study put out
by a group of researchers at yale and
what they showed is that their advice
was everyone every single investor
should use 100 leverage in their 401k
they should lever up as much as they
possibly can in their 401k and they
showed historically that that was the
right thing to do because even if you
got completely wiped out even if you
your portfolio went to zero because of
your leverage as long as you pick
yourself up the next day and bought
stocks with two times leverage over time
you would you would earn like an extra
three percentage points of return and
they were dead serious in this report
and the math all works out it works on
the chalkboard on the spreadsheet
they're right it's the right thing to do
in the real world
people would not work there's no real
world in which someone would watch their
retirement portfolio go to zero and then
the next day keep doing the same thing
that's just not how people's heads work
and so
there's a lot of things in finance that
that look smart and sound smart and the
numbers add up and it's just completely
opposed to how the real world works i i
i'd write in the book that the
difference between being rational and
reasonable and there are a lot of things
that investors do that are not rational
but i think they're perfectly reasonable
and they align with how people's heads
work one of which i would i would say is
there's this well-documented home bias
with investors where you know by and
large people who live in america only
own u.s stocks and people who live in
germany only own german stocks in japan
so on people own the stocks that are
closest to where they live which is not
rational at all it's not irrational to
think like the best stocks are the ones
that are closest to your house that's
crazy but that's how people invest and
it's not rational but it's actually very
reasonable if taking the leap of faith
of investing your life savings in these
companies if it's easier to do that when
you're most familiar with them that's
totally a reasonable thing to do
and so i think that difference between
reasonable and rational is really
important i've read about in the book
too that my wife and i don't have a
mortgage on our house which is the worst
financial decision we've ever made and i
would never try to justify it on a
spreadsheet because i can't it's a
terrible it's a terrible financial
decision but it's been the best money
decision that we've ever made it's given
us more joy and pleasure than of
anything that we've done with our money
even though it's the worst financial
decision we've ever made just because it
gives us a sense of independence and
security and particularly when we're
raising our kids like this is our house
it's not the bank's house this is our
house i cannot rationalize that tim on a
spreadsheet i can't but it makes me
happy and so that that difference
between the spreadsheet in the real
world is so important everyone thinks
about it a little bit differently but i
i
turn my nose a little bit at the
academics who just live inside of excel
and think that's how the world works and
i respect a lot more the kind of gritty
people on the street that understand how
the real world works and how people's
brains works what makes them tick and
how things actually play out
yeah
and i should also volunteer
that
maybe four years ago five years ago i
was having a conversation with a very
financially successful friend of mine
who's also done a very
a great job of crafting an unusual
just trying to think of how to tiptoe
around some of his adventures exciting
life for himself that
is is just quintessentially him right
it's like unapologetically non-consensus
and he seems to just have a great time
in life and he's he's made a lot of
very
deliberate decisions and i i wanted to
get some advice from him about something
and he asked me to lay out
what my current kind of balance sheet
looked like and i laid it out and he
said
why do you have this mortgage left or
this amount left on your mortgage on
your house and i said well
blah blah blah i gave him the kind of
spreadsheet justification right like
interest rates are low it's basically
free money blood that the tough i can
take that money and do blah blah blah
and he said just pay it off he said just
having the peace of mind that no matter
what you have a house that cannot be
taken away
is going to do more for your ability to
sleep at night than anything else he's
like it doesn't make sense
mathematically
but
pay off the mortgage and he was right
psychologically the payoff was
tremendous and
i guess if we think of
investing or one way to think of
investing being
allocating capital to improve your
quality of life then it is a good
investment right to pay it off totally
makes sense i'm not recommending that
for everybody this is just my own story
but i ended up
in the same place as yourself for that
reason i also know a lot of people for
whom that would be a terrible decision
they could not live with themselves if
they knew that they were leaving money
on the table so it works for me and my
wife and you it sounds like and other
people it wouldn't and that's where i
get down to like all all of this is just
personal and whatever works for you and
there's something about money where that
that can irk people like there's some
people when i tell them i don't have a
mortgage they they get angry at it
because i've it's such a bad financial
decision and in a way that like other
things in life don't work like that if
if you said i like classical music i
might say cool that's great i don't but
that's fine i don't think any less of
you i'm not gonna argue with you about
it's just that's your taste this is mine
and but for financial decisions people
really don't like that because and i
think those are people who only view it
as a spreadsheet endeavor versus using
capital to give yourself a better life
like you mentioned
you